Russian President Vladimir Putin has
claimed victory in Mario Paul saying his
forces have successfully liberated the
port city in Southeastern Ukraine Putin
ordered his military to blockade the
city's abasov Stars steel plants sealing
Ukrainian troops and civilians inside
here's a clip from his televised meeting
with his defense minister segele
I consider the proposed storming of the
Industrial Area pointless I ordered to
abort it
this is a case when we must think we
must always think but even more so in
this case about preserving the life and
health of our soldiers and officers
there is no need to climb into these
catacombs and crawl Underground through
these industrial facilities block off
this industrial area so that not even a
fly can get through here
the ASAP style steel plant is the last
place in Mario Paul still in Ukrainian
hands Russia says more than 2 000
Ukrainian troops are holding out in the
heavily fortified plant Ukrainian
officials say around 1 000 civilians are
also seeking Refuge there with food
running low Kiev is demanding that
Moscow open a humanitarian Corridor to
let civilians flee
Let's cross to Kiev now where DW
correspondent Rebecca ritters is
standing by Rebecca what more can you
tell us about the situation now in Mario
Paul
well you heard it there from the horse's
mouth President Putin acclaiming victory
of Mary upoll for the Russians we
haven't had confirmation of from the
Ukrainian side but it's not unexpected
Terry have been expecting Mario Paul to
fall to Russian control for some days
now but in reality
territorially nothing really has shifted
since prior to the statement by
President Putin they have for some days
actually held control of the city and of
the port but not of that as of steel
plant as you've just reported and That
Remains the Same still thought to be 2
000 or so Defenders and around about a
thousand civilians hiding in tunnels in
the vast tunnel Network under that as of
steel plant but there has been a shift
tactically as you heard there President
Putin calling for assessing of the
bombardment of that steel plant and
instead to be blockaded it's not exactly
clear why that directive was given
whether or not perhaps they want to to
keep that steel plant intact so that if
and when they do gain control of it they
can still use it or perhaps they do
indeed need to save some face there and
change that tactically because they
haven't been able to root out those
remaining Defenders
so what's going to become of those
people in that steel plant Rebecca both
the soldiers and the civilians and I
understand there are also around a
hundred thousand civilians left
elsewhere in Mario Paul
that's right well the fate of the
soldiers and those civilians are at the
steel plant it really remains to be seen
a President Putin has said that he
guarantees their safety should they
surrender but those troops have ignored
previous
seasoned assist orders by the Russians
to come out with their hands up
assuming that they don't trust President
Putin and the Russians that they will in
fact be taken to safety one of the
Battalion leaders has actually come out
calling for an extraction by
International forces and that they be
taken to neutral territory and that
looking very unlikely at this stage so
not entirely clear what's going to
happen to them but you heard it there
from President Putin no fly shall pass
so what's the situation elsewhere in
eastern and southern Ukraine Rebecca
what's the latest in the battle for Don
Bass
yes well that expected battle for Don
bass has entered its Third Day Terry
we've seen really an increasing a really
large increasing in bombardments in that
area particularly in the city of hard
Kiev today the mayor has come out and
said it's been under almost constant
bombardment very worried for the some 1
million people still living in that City
uh other areas luhan's being in the
donbass region being very badly shelled
as well the mayor there saying that the
civilians have no power no water and
utilities won't be able to be restored
until after the war and of course
mikalayov to the South has also been
bombarded that's another city down south
near the other key port city of Odessa
so we're definitely seeing a huge uptick
in fighting in that region
Rebecca thank you very much our
correspondent Rebecca Ritter's in Kieth
Ukrainian investigators are carrying out
the painstaking work of exhuming bodies
from makeshift Graves it's part of an
effort to gather evidence of alleged war
crimes committed by Russian troops while
forensic teams do their work relatives
of those killed wait nearby to claim
their loved ones our correspondent
Matthias Bellinger joined other
journalists on a visit to the town of
borodianca near Kiev he spoke to one
mother whose son never came home
for the police it has become a grim
routine dozens of musk Graves have been
opened here in the past few weeks
but for nadeja boyko this is the day she
has been waiting for her son is being
exhumed today
he was on his way back he called to say
he'd be home soon but he never came
to in boyko was shot on the street in
the early days of the war his body was
given a makeshift burial on the grounds
of a hospital when the morgue had to
close because it had no power
police say that here in the northern
suburbs of Kiev they have recovered more
than 1 000 parties
the town of portoyanka was heavily
shelled and then occupied by Russian
forces
life is still far from normal with
supermarkets and shops looted and
destroyed people here depend on Aid
deliveries to survive
at the hospital police have exhumed nine
bodies today there were civilians who
were shot in the streets or run over by
tanks some have yet to be identified
unfortunately we'll be doing this work
for many more years but we'll work as
quickly and as thoroughly as possible so
we have sold evidence to hold the
aggressor accountable in the
international courts not only those who
did it but also those who ordered it
the recovered bodies are being sent to
the morgue for forensic examination and
will then be returned to their relatives
always to kill him
I know that his soul is gone I know this
is just a body but it's the body that I
used to hug and love
it's my child I cry every day
calls one small Comfort but soon she
will be able to bury her son properly